[Musique]
je me baisse pour refermer mais mes
lacets je me relève elle était partie
c'est que jamais toi tu fais des fées
dopent la fonction ça se calme et puis
je vais chanter pour lui a dit qu'elle
était un chien et d'imagerie les dix
clubs où j'ai envie qu'il faut le dire
pour lui dire on peut venir grédy
prennent la fois trouver un milieu
humide vous à l'équipe une
tu vas rentrer d'accord mais moi je
pense que c'est parce que je suis pas
moi je suis sûr combien illimité mais
raisonnable c'est vrai en sortie limitée
la magistrate chargée des déchets le
trou ils sont à remplacer
j'aimerais acheter des boucles
d'oreilles du maquillage des sonneurs
pour ma grand-mère croco monde
bush et bsat-3b bois
[Musique]
oui
non
gros ça fait partie libre égale et elle
a trouvé son bonheur
j'ai fait deux pour 50 d'émouvoir quand
tu prends plus sur lui
à la recherche d yeux que pour celui des
services
c'est en quoi ça s'achète par deux très
beaux mais vous allez bonne queen très
bon ça la dendre
c'est pas cher encore vendée voyait pss
25 10 l'ajax oui c'est avec tous les
lèches boules de l'émission sont comme
ça les plus polis voulait pas qu'on est
comme ça envoyait par me isabelle oger
assez comme ça vous n'avez pas des
banquiers doit même être sûr que ça
fasse dans faust dans nos draps combien
ça saccade hnf graal positionner caisse
certes on n'a failli jamais toi qu'on a
assez dépensé d'argent pour aujourd'hui
je suis pas fier pour ma fille parce que
vous êtes un bon vendeur parce qu'on
n'était pas du tout
à la base j'étais pas comment on fait
quoi sur l'étalagé chimiste a debate
marzin combien ça coûte quoi aller alors
je me suis dit je te fais 30 dinars pour
le plaisir on va au bout du rouleau avec
ta copine et non pas pour moi mais dès
que vous aviez de patchouli vous n'avez
pas que tu vas arrêter la musique à
l'elysée mois
tu as raison
cyril va acheter magasins en fait la
peau je peux parler de minutes on en est
où je suis moi je remets un kadhafi
coût 14 400 points je massage et le
groupe a aussi si tu veux te donne on
sent maintenant et sans la semaine
prochaine
non merci
voilà
[Musique]
on s'est régalé